[Music]
the force it moves through and surrounds
every living thing it's calling to you
the force awakens is the movie event of
a generation its history making
a stunning piece of entertainment
[Music]
and disabled when you bring it home
there's even more energy including a
full-length documentary han and chewie
entering the [ __ ] absolutely amazing
you know look what we get to do an
exclusive deleted seeds
[Music]
ships clear
baby don't let me now
you
hey youtubers is charlie if you guys
didn't know the DVD for star wars the
force awakens is coming out really soon
but if you buy the digital edition you
can get it sooner so I'm just going to
explain what's on the DVD what all the
special features are there a bunch of
deleted scenes and when you can tell
them to shut up and take my money so
here's the deal if you absolutely cannot
wait for a physical DVD the earliest you
can get a copy an HD copy of the movie
is April first that'll be available on
iTunes Amazon anywhere you can buy
instant video there are several
different versions of the DVD in the
blu-ray that you can buy just depending
on where you buy it but all the special
features are the same so unless you want
one of the steelbook editions of the DVD
which is being sold by best buy I would
just recommend you buy from amazon but
if you buy from the disney store you'll
get a couple lithographs which are
basically just pictures from the movie
unless you really like to collect things
like that i would recommend just buying
the amazon blu-ray you get a little bit
quicker amazon's pretty reliable but
it's not like if you buy the DVD from
one place you'll get special features
that aren't on another copy of the dbd
from another store so what are the
special features there's a bunch of
different things there's secrets of the
force awakens the cinematic journey
that's just a documentary about making
the movie it's going to be a lot of fun
the story awakens the table read that's
just the actors reading the script for
the first time together like this right
here when they were doing this building
bb-8 crafting creatures that's like
going on a tour of Star Wars Creature
Shop like watching them actually make be
be watching the process of them make all
these creatures blueprint of a battle
the snow fight that's ray kylo Ren
fighting in the snow Finn was in there
too but he didn't last very long but
this is like the behind the scenes of
their fights specifically the visual
magic of the force that's just them
talking about the behind the scenes for
actually doing force effects John
Williams the seventh Symphony obviously
behind the scenes of John Williams
crafting the score for the movie force
for change that's just like a mini
documentary about all the charities that
the actors did associated with the movie
they did special contest that were tied
to charities and then all the beautiful
deleted scenes how many deleted scenes
are there they're supposed to be six
there might be more but these are what
their call we can speculate on them in a
second there's Finn in the villager then
jacuzzi then x-wings prepare for
Lightspeed then kylo Ren searches the
Falcon that was actually in the trailer
him on board the Millennium Falcon snow
speeder chase through
a big battle scene during that big final
battle on the Starkiller base that was
cut and all these snow troopers we
really just saw the x-wing fight we
didn't see the fight on the ground and
then the last one is fin will be fine
that sounds self-explanatory they get
Finn back to the resistance base and
start to fix his broke ass so remember
now even if you pre-order the bluray you
won't get it till april fifth but i
think it's worth it just because the
quality is going to be so much better
the only reason i would say not to buy
the blu-ray is if you don't have a
blu-ray player or you don't own a TV
like all of the things that you watch
are on your computer then go for the
digital download you can still get the
special features but if you order it on
amazon right now it is ten dollars off
the blu-rays normally thirty dollars but
you can get it for 20 now if you
pre-order on amazon and i imagine that
deal would be good all the way up to
April fourth so it's not like you have
to preorder it right now to get the
discount in case you have to Panhandle
your parents for extra money but I can
see some of the more mature people in
the back saying but hey wait aren't they
going to release an even bigger edition
of the DVD this Christmas shopping
season won't there be a collector's
edition eventually yes that will totally
happen so if you want to hold off in the
collector's edition I have no idea when
they're going to release that but just
like they released collected editions of
all the other Star Wars movies once they
release the next couple of Star Wars
movies they'll also be the same types of
special editions where they happen to
find extra bonus features that they left
off the earlier DVD releases that was
the funny thing they did when they
released the very first Star Wars
blu-ray edition it was a collected
Edition for the prequel trilogy and for
the original trilogy and they released a
whole bunch of bonus features that they
had never released before on any
addition of any home video format my
favorite was Luke assembling his new
lightsaber in a cave on Tatooine before
he went into Jabba's palace so don't be
surprised if in a couple years there's
an even bigger edition of the star wars
blu ray and later tonight if you guys
didn't know there's a new episode of
walking dead I'll post my video after
the episode airs there's a whole lot of
comic book stuff going on right now
negan is on the way why you guys wait
for me to post that video tonight you
can click here for my top 10 favorite
game of thrones foreshadowing scenes and
you can click here for all my Star Wars
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight me me me me me
you